You're going to get knocked down.
A long business relationship will come to a sudden end.
A contract won't be renewed.
A lover will call it a day.
People will suddenly be weird with you.
They'll keep you out of lovely things and you won't know why.
You'll read about yourself on social media
and every worst fear will be confirmed.
Quite a lot of things go wrong over a lifetime
and you'll want to die and throw it all in
and quit this painful world.
When you look at a child, this is what's coming to them.
That's what makes it moving to look at a baby sleeping
You're looking at innocence through the lens of painful experience.
Oh my, they are going to suffer and there's simply nothing you can do to help them.
Apart from one thing...
Teach them that the suffering is normal.
It isn't a sign that life has gone wrong.
It's an ordinary part of everyone's biography.
The only way, is to learn to fight!
The temptation would be to withdraw under a rock.
To pull up the drawbridge; to go into a shell.
But the challenges are like a fire, a bed of coals you have to walk across.
The fight has to be expected.
The difficulties are a sign that things are on track.
That you're being rejected, that there are haters, isn't evidence that your life is a ruin.
It's proof that you've found something worth living for.